again Griffin with Griffin tell your
friends ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
[Music]
podcast
FL yeah w w wo yeah
[Music]
Baby Woo golden pipes is back
baby I think that's because of the
workouts uh you know what I mean but
anyways today short episode I guess uh
still talking about sag man they got a
these negotiations are up and down dude
F food price is going up in California I
called it plus some more news and notes
from around the
world um yeah just you know you know how
we do here on riffin with Griffin once
again thank you you know what it is it's
[Music]
real
W them pipe sounding good today boy I
think it's all from the workout you can
see on my face Daddy slimming down but
anyways I want to thank everybody for
being here on riffin with Griffin man I
don't know what is this shaking for you
guys I wonder why it it does that I have
to I I'm gonna have to somehow fix that
because I don't like that it does that
but anyways um you know come check
out twitch you know how I do it I'm on
Twitch if you want to support you could
be a sub be a patreon person yeah it is
shaking like that look at that I got a
fix that I don't know what that is when
you go to this one isn't that crazy how
there's always something on my on my
damn thing all weighs something like why
is it making the thing like that's I
don't know what that is but anyways also
be patreon member so thank you very much
for the people that support the show
financially I appreciate that very much
today's episode is brought to you by
door Dash a favorite sponsor of the show
use code rgw holiday to get 50% off up
to $10 value when you spend $15 or more
at a convenience grocery or select
retail stores on the door Dash app terms
apply thank you door dash for being here
and and somewhat of a sponsor of the
show I got to give them a shout out
because they do me well too is uh wait
let me do it this way is ewin racing
they make these great gaming chairs ewin
racing and they just sent me a new one
and this one is dopee so this one has
like a uh what is this a
magnetic pillow that you can put in
different
spots chair my back's feeling good you
know so anyways shout out to Ean raying
and I will have a code uh if you're on
my twitch if you want to get a chair
because they give good discounts for my
followers so thank you for
that ewin racing thanks for being a part
of the um Griffin with Griffin
community so welcome chat thanks for
being here let me put up
uh Q&A for people in chat if they got
something when I go to my comments let
me know what you got going on there all
right what's going on today um you know
had my third workout today went to um
you know it's tough man I mean it's like
I don't know if you haven't worked out
in a while and you just starting to work
out you know how it is I mean there's
people that like work out all the time
and then they're used to the workout
regimen and they know and even when they
say they take off for two weeks and
they're like they go back and go oh man
today was hard that kind of hard is
different from the like you just been
letting yourself go hard and then my age
but you know I have to remind myself
that like when I'm walking home cuz it's
nearby so I get to walk it's like a
15minute walk and then a 15-minute walk
back obviously and then you know it's
just like I do feel
so much better um afterwards but it's
just man is it hard to get yourself
there right my goodness just this
morning I was just like I don't want to
do this and I I just go oh man that's
the feeling like that's how you feel you
just go I don't want to do this um so
let me just not go or just not do this
today so like that
self-discipline is what you have to like
I have have to like train myself to get
to like no no no CU even when the
training stops when I finish with my
sessions my 24 sessions or whatever it
is I you know I got to maintain I want
to be able to like you know it doesn't
have to be a lot but man the things that
we're doing in there is like you know
what some of the hardest things for me
is like just getting up off the ground
like my guy is watching me get off off
the ground and he's like yo stop using
your hands like like putting my hands on
my knees or something like that you know
to get up off the ground like those
kinds of things he's likeo man you got
to stop that so you know it's tough
man um but you know so I'm realizing
like oh wow like these like little
things I'm having trouble with are like
the the you know some of the hardest
parts of the the the workout process but
you you guys out there working out you
know you know you know what it is you
know you know how that is you know how
hard it is to
uh you know and then you know so we do
like a lot of ground workor so right now
I'm doing like these like scissor
exercises on the ground uh you know uh
you know lifting my core up and like
like I have my legs on this like yoga
ball then I like lift myself up I lift
my my my midsection up and then pull the
ball in I got to do 12 of those a few
sets of those and just those that ground
work stuff I'll be like oh my God it's
just my own body weight and I'm out
there dying and then we lift you know
and that I actually like that better I
like but then as the as he starts to
increase we weight you know so I'm doing
like four sets of like these different
things so it'll be like curls with the
the chest stuff and then some traps and
some just all kinds of stuff that I
don't even know what it is uh and it's
you know it's weird when you walking
around the gym and then like it is like
you see all these pretty women at the
gym you know and you're just kind of
like damn this
is you know what you have to like you
know they're in there just doing their
thing and you're just like oh man I'm
just the fat guy in here but I guess
that's like you know you know you want
you want to look good for yourself for
your family you you know what I
mean just like you see them in there I
always feel like they side eying me like
what's this
tubby and I'm thinking to myself you
just wait you just
wait but um
yeah it's good workout today guys good
workout so
anyways what else is going on um oh you
know I gotta tell you I still love my
car Lucid air touring check it out shout
out to Lucid uh and then they had this
whole thing where like you know I I've
given some suggestions and they're
really like oh okay yeah man we're going
to see about that you know because
there's like some there's like you know
the car I don't know who if if anybody's
car uses Alexa any Alexa people so like
the thing is with Alexa I think that
like Alexa if you have it in your car it
should have its own menu option what I
mean by that is like sometimes you have
these different menu options and one of
them will be like you know the different
applications so let's say it's like um
you know music or Spotify right so then
when you click Spotify on your screens
whatever it's all the Spotify stuff you
know recently played uh playlists and
all this kind of stuff
so Alexa interacts with the car but it's
like there's no menu for it so like I
listen to you know Audi books so I'll be
like Alexa play audiobook and then the
audio book will start to play from where
I left off on my phone or wherever I'm
listening to it but there's no screen
there's no like menu option where I
could be like oh let me go to this other
book now that it's opened so either like
add audible as a app or I just feel like
Alexa itself has its whole other things
so when you go to the Alexa app on your
phone phone like you could add things
there and it shows up in the car you
know just by voice command cuz I'll be
like you know Alexa call my wife and
then the first time I did that it was
like well who's your wife tell me who
your wife is in your contacts you know
and I was like okay Rachel Griffin and
then it was like I'll remember that but
then when I went to the phone in the
Alexa app I saw it there so I was like
oh well that's cool but like it seems to
be separate from the car um stuff
so
anyways um you know so that's just some
things so I don't know like if anybody
else has a
car that uses Alexa do you find that
same thing you know I would love to hear
about that in the uh comments if you
have that same kind of thing so you know
like I say I've said before I I like I
like the electric car thing because I
love overthe a updates I love that I
love that you get in your car and then
like ooh they changed the the thing and
you're like ooh it's almost like a new
car you know so it's great I haven't
gotten the
full uh mileage that they said the range
they say you could get on the car yet
and I know that's supposed to De it
develops over time and I I don't even
have a th000 miles on the car yet but
right now I'm at like 380 so when I do
when I charge my car full overnight or
however long you know it's like 380
which is really still pretty great but
you're supposed to get 415 so I'm
waiting to see that 400 on my thing I
want to see that and that's really dope
I don't know if you guys know this but
if you have electric cars out there you
should call your electric company
because you can get a discount on your
electric bill or I didn't realize this
that they had different rate plans on
the electricity so like you could like
they have and then here's something else
this is so the different hours of the
day when the the the grid is using wind
solar and other forms of energy I didn't
even know that was going on but
apparently like from 4 to 9 from 4 to 9
is the most expensive time for
electricity and that's because you know
the Sun is going down or whatever the
case may be or more people are on the
grid at that time that's when it's most
expensive so like if you got an electric
car you should set your car between like
start charging from 8:00 a.m. to 4: or
start charging 9:00 a.m. on I didn't
even know this uh apparently like in
California that's like from eight to
whatever is when the solar grids and the
wind and all this stuff I didn't even
know we were using that stuff so feels
to me like the electricity should be
even lower you know so we'll
see um we'll see what's going on with
that
so you know what I
mean
um anyways so let's get to the comments
and I appreciate everybody that you know
puts a comment you know that's uh fun
stuff let's see um well here's one bad
comment you know we can start with the
bad comment I swear this is has to be
the most candy ass product ever
made well I don't actually he's not even
talking about the podcast he's talking
about this this uh smart toilet I
think I saw the word podcast in my mind
but he said product so he wasn't even
really talking about see I'm looking for
hate look at
me um let's see so that
was I am the stone the
builder refused oh my God I hate all of
you and your stupid
names all right 48 Boogie fastex was
crazy I couldn't stop laughing Jason was
funny AF oh yeah who's black Ley or
Dom H yeah I can't wait for fast X2 to
come out so I can do that
one I can't wait for
that somebody said currently binging the
Lee
episodes Noah yeah these episodes people
keep watching them over and over again
it's really funny those guys I don't
know if they're ever be back
though um let's see what we got here I
saw a good one
earlier let's
see uh NQ 6508 two days ago and this is
from an old episode with
Giovani he should put money away for a
house a small City instead of that car
let's his relatives live in until till
his career takes a dive and he could
just retire there that's the advice
I don't know some people are like just
enjoy I've I've seen a lot of
people like when you give give advice to
somebody that just got rich or just has
a bunch of money now and they just go
like what what do you guys think it's
like should you save your money and or
or is there a part of you that you
should also enjoy life you know I mean
I'm I'm a Believer in in both I believe
I believe there has to be a balance you
know that's why I think that you
should you should save money right but
you know doesn't mean you have to be
like so Frugal about everything because
I think Quality quality of life is
important it it really is man you flying
home from someplace and you're just not
feeling good hey upgrade yourself maybe
you made a lot it's it's going to be a
lot of money but there's just something
about how you're going to feel about
yourself when you when you know when you
get to your destination got this new
glasses cleaner I wanted to try it out
so I don't I don't know I just think
sometimes you have to you have to have a
balance you know you don't want to be
one of these people that didn't do
anything you didn't enjoy anything you
know that's why you work you work hard
so you can play hard you know I don't
know there's a balance I think you
should have in life and some people just
don't have that
balance Marty the zebra said it's all in
the diet Griff I know you can get back
to your pandemic slim self again well I
wasn't Slim in a pandemic but thank you
uh it's not all in the diet the diet is
super important but uh exercise is
important like people that just diet
that's not enough you do have to get
some get your heart pumping get your
blood flowing through your your your
muscles and all that stuff man having
movement and activity is important for
your brain for your heart so yes I know
all you people who talk about like oh
you know you eat too much you eat eat
you know it's that is super important
too but don't downplay the I the just
regular movement is super important you
even if it's just going on a 20 minute
walk every day or something these are
all the things I'm finding out about so
you know we got to do those things
man somebody said would love for you to
come to Orlando I'll be looking out I
was supposed to go to Orlando but then
they you know canceled the show so I'm
looking for another play I actually
found a place so I'm setting up another
show in Orlando so if people look out
and speaking of shows um tomorrow night
if you're in the New Jersey New
Brunswick area New Jersey people I'm
going to be at the stre best Factory for
one night I'm directing another special
uh this funny dude Martin amini I'm
doing his special uh so he's going to be
there the weekend he's going to be there
Friday and Saturday so I'm going to
watch him and give notes and we're going
to be working on his stuff and I said
you know what let me just see if I can
get a night so I got the Thursday night
so check look for me if you want to see
me live and you're in New Jersey you
know someone in New Jersey tell your
friends
whatever go to the stress Factory in New
Brunswick Vinnie BR Stress Factory I
will be
there tomorrow Thursday November 9th
come and check me out
people all right guys it's that time
again uh to talk about our beautiful
sponsor of the show door Dash it is the
season to skip the store in St in store
Rush
when the holidays knock answer the door
Dash get holiday groceries and gifts
delivered fast and enjoy everything you
need for hosting and toasting you know
what I mean like you throw in a party
and you need some paper plates boom door
Dash maybe you forgot you know some some
some uh Christmas decorations or some
Thanksgiving stuff door Dash it's that
magical time of year here make the
holidays look easy with door Dash get
the gifts they want and the ingredients
you you need fast from stocking stuffers
to stuffing all in one app as a door
dash pass member you can enjoy exclusive
offers and perks all season long on
stocking stuffers Decor groceries meals
and more you'll get a zero delivery fee
and reduced service fees on eligible
orders too I love door Dash I use it all
the time look guys order now and get the
holiday help you need from door Dash use
code RW G holiday all one word rwg
holiday to get 50% off up to $10 value
when you spend $15 or more at
convenience grocery or select retail
stores on door Dash terms
apply yeah so thanks door dash for being
a
sponsor all right guys let's uh I'm
going to go back here and just a
quick look at
some Q&A questions that people might
have asked right
now uh jinong baby update oh thank you
for saying that baby update so we got
the crib the crib is built H that was
fun to do so when we put the wallpaper
up we almost got
divorced just I don't know if you've
ever put Furniture together or done
anything with your spouse that is a
nightmare but now we're in a Groove and
it's all good we we put that together
the baby room's cleaned out we had to
call maintenance today for them to put
the fix the AC cuz cuz the room we're
using for the baby room it was a little
warm and I was like I don't think the AC
is working so they change the filter for
that today but the baby room's coming
along great we got wallpaper on the wall
uh you know once we get it all cleaned
out how we like it and everything's
ready to go then I'm gonna hire a hire
someone to come in and just like steam
clean the carpets and you know make sure
everything's all good there even though
the baby probably won't won't be in
there but you know I've heard different
advice from different people that like
you know get the baby used to being in
its own space as soon as you can but you
know then you hear other things where
it's like the first six months the baby
doesn't even know it's a different it's
a its own person that it feels like it's
still a part of the
mom and skin toin contact with the dad
and you hear they get the smell and they
know it's you and it's like so who knows
man there's no right or wrong way but
I'm excited for the whole
process but the baby stuff's going great
so once I have this room all set up and
everything then I'mma I'mma you know I I
can even when I'm on the podcast go live
when I'm live like this I can like go to
my phone and take you into the room so
you guys can see it
live but anyways thanks for that
question reminding me to go into that uh
what do you think of the young OKC
Thunder team oh man man you know what I
think all the teams like anytime a team
is Young and you go oh they're good it
it really doesn't matter until the
playoffs come and they can and they can
overcome the playoff Jitters and when
the best of the best is playing against
each other can they overcome that
because look at Sacramento last year
they were a great young team second seed
in the west and we thought oh man they
had no shot against a veteran Squad like
the Lakers or Golden State it just is
what it is you know so I think they're
good but let's see how it plays out
throughout the season how they play
against good teams and then when the
playoffs start will they be ready that's
the question we have for all the teams
really right how you regulate food and
fitness well portion portions are really
what's important you know that's the
biggest problem we all have is how much
we eat it's like what you eat and then
how much much of it do you eat so you
know I'm trying to like really cut back
so I'm replacing a meal with a protein
shake and then I'm making sure that I if
I have a protein shake and a huge meal
I'm making sure I have a salad or
something as the other meal something
smaller too so I'm trying to work on
regulating that that's a really good
question did you watch spider-verse I
did I enjoyed that movie a lot I enjoyed
the spider-verse movies um I just didn't
like that they you know well you know
it's like they had a cliffhanger and I
thought it was a great Cliffhanger on
the last one so we'll see we'll see
where it goes I would like to see that
live action but the cartoon's great you
know I love the cartoon and then and
then like I watched Loki Loki's oh man I
have to have a whole segment about that
show and like how it really fits in in
the in the MCU which I don't think
they're even really doing anymore I
think the MCU is dead I think they're
not worrying about continuity or
anything anymore I think think they
failed and they're just going to you
know they're going to figure it out
after that now they're just do something
else
uh let's see oh see somebody asked me
about that the last person asked me
about that H so that's pretty cool um
anyways thanks for your questions guys
uh I appreciate that okay so now let's
get into some stuff so you know the SAG
strike still going on uh they went to
the table um you know what's crazy is
like they said the words this is our
last and best offer when I heard that I
was like well we're not ending the
strike to me those are the worst words
you could say in a negotiation ever to
anyone ever hey this is it take it or
leave it it can't be take it or leave it
because you can't do anything without
the
actors like I don't
understand
you know you look at the the net worth
of the studio exx you look at the net
worth of the studio itself like this is
how much profit the studio is generating
and you just go man like what are you
talking about man you're telling me that
this is this is it like you you like
like like you don't want to have a
relationship with the reason people
come to watch TV shows movies and all
that like a huge reason why people watch
stuff is the actor that's in the show
you know the the writing like what do
the Studios have to do with the art of
it other than they're fronting the
money uh you know which is huge I'm not
going to take it away from that you know
to sell refrigerators and whatnot but
damn best in final offer you think
that's gonna I don't
know now the big stickler I'm hearing
right now is
um AI like you know and this is my big
like this drives me bananas so if I play
a song right now on my YouTube page
right now during this podcast if I go on
Spotify or if I like go on even if I
play a karaoke version of a song it's
flagged man they're like oh I'm going to
be demonetized IED or it's going to be
like well you can still monetize but a
portion of this profit is going to go
to the artist of the song that I played
like 10 seconds of it or 20 you know
what I mean like I'm playing this song
and somehow it means that that person
now owns my whole podcast like That's
How Strong the music intellectual
property is that that you know you play
a song on your Instagram without going
through that like song thing
you just playing a song in the back like
if you're going live on Instagram and
you're playing music in the background
they'll turn off your live they'll be
like oh you're playing music but I can't
do that for my face my
voice what
Studios what the [__] is wrong with you
you're telling me I don't own
me I don't own me so you could just use
my face my voice however the [__] you
want and I don't get anything for that
but if I play a
song from somebody the whole [__] gets
shut
down make that make
sense full
stop unbelievable
so I think they're going to finally
change the wording of
this
but I still think it's a
distraction you know it's
like what does the
studios lose by saying okay all right
we'll um okay you're right AI we won't
do it they weren't doing it before so
they're not losing or gaining anything
it to me it's just a distraction to
Sag this should really all be about the
money the whole thing should be about
how much money we're going to get right
but now it's all about AI hold the AI oh
Ai and the studios are
like no we want to use Ai and then we're
like you you stop it and then they go
okay you know what guys you're right we
won't use Ai and then we go like this
yay we won what did we win that they
weren't using it before it's still about
money I don't get it I don't get
it I don't get it so we'll see where it
goes
man um we will see where it goes all
right let's go to my uh favorite
Instagram stories of the week here's one
of the first ones I I thought was
interesting so Selen Gomez deleting
Instagram after being blasted over
Israel Palestine
post okay she got like 300 million
followers
this is my
thing you don't got to announce it just
leave and I'm not even saying it's her
fault like you know what I mean she's so
famous and popular that it's like
anything she does people want to be like
hey let's talk about this you
know
[Music]
um you know what I mean so I'm like but
it's like I hate when people do this I
hate when people do like I didn't like
what Pete Davidson was doing this like
Pete Davids was like uh oh I'm leaving
social media but he still had his
Instagram account he just deleted all
his posts deleted all his F you still
got Instagram you know what I mean you
still got it like is she is that what
she's gonna do I don't even know if she
did it or not actually let's go and
check and see if Selena Gomez is
um
[Music]
um let me see anybody know any making go
to it let's see if she's let's see if
she actually left Instagram
Selena Selena
Selena Gomez here we go let's see no no
she's still there Selena Gomez still
here guys still here 430 million
followers and it's probably like a
million dollars every time she
posts guess who's still on
Instagram I mean you
know I don't know I mean I guess the
thing to really talk about is like you
know this this like what a what a
subject to like
be um Kick like you know given [__] for
but yeah man this is a big conflict
that's going on you know that makes me
feel like I should say something how I
feel about it again I don't like what's
going on I mean I just got to say right
now I don't like what's going on I saw a
post uh Instagram post about the doctors
from you know doctors Beyond board ERS
you know and they're over there and
they're just they they can't believe
what's going on you know they're they're
operating on people with no no
anesthesia they have the the they have
to operate on people outside you know
there's not enough beds for people that
are injured it's like man this is such a
crazy nuanced situation but it's like
you
know they go to they got to stop the war
part of it like this is not gonna like
they're not going like they're not going
to be able to
stop or change people's minds with war
all they're doing is they're
creating Fighters for the
future you know if thousands of children
are dying because of this
conflict they're they're just
creating these families are going to be
in ruin and then now they're they're
they're going to be feeling the same way
they're going to be like well now we got
to come after you and it's never going
to
end you know it's never going to end by
by by using
violence I don't I wish I had the answer
I'm no Diplomat I just don't like what
I'm seeing I don't know who's right or
wrong I just know the way it's being
handled now it ain't the
way
sucks all right let's get back back to
the let's get back to my posts my
Instagram posts
so this I found this super interesting
the UK plans to ban
smoking and it was confirmed by King
Charles I don't know why he's involved
but just the
idea
that like this is
awesome and something that should happen
everywhere imagine that they ban like
this could be the start of banning
things that are bad for people like yeah
you know it's like they should ban the
amount of sugar that they put in food
they should ban the amount of like corn
syrup or they should ban like you know
how things are made and and and
artificial uh things but like
smoking like smoking if you look up the
amount of deaths that smoking
causes you know
if I just Google actually I'm going go
to like the uh let's let me go to the
one of the let me go to the the AI like
I love my Google
AI uh death deaths due to smoking
yearly you
know and here it is right here guys in
the United States the Center for Disease
Control and prevention CDC estimates
that smoking related diseases cause over
480 deaths each
year this includes deaths from lung
cancer heart disease stroke and other
smoking related
illnesses the economic burden of smoking
is also significant in the United States
alone smoking related medical costs are
estimated to be over 300 $30 billion
each year you hear
that let's get rid of smoking right like
deaths a
year okay
um I mean I'm just I'm just Googling
something else real quick I want to I
want to look and
see
okay what are we talking about here
let's see
um I don't want to say this just yet
till I see what they're oh they don't
have a number I wanted to see I wanted
to see the number I wanted to see the
number since
2019 like how many deaths have there
been caused by
coid since
2019 cuz it's 2019 2020 2021 2002 2023
so already we know right there because
of smoking at almost 500,000 people die
a year you're talking about you know 1
Milli 2 you know it's almost almost
three million people have died because
of smoking you know what I
mean it's like this I don't know you get
what I'm saying this shit's this shit's
crazy you know it's it's it's bananas
but you know I look at this story and I
think well maybe this is like a start of
something because you know Europe has
already taken out that the little red
dye and and there's there's Foods in
Europe that we have also have here that
there's ingredients that we have that
are
illegal in certain European
countries so these are our allies and
they're doing it for public health
reasons and I think we should too so who
knows but smoking is
like I don't know mean do you right but
if we make it illegal or just get rid of
it you know what I mean can we get rid
of it or is that too uh optimistic of me
to think all right let's talk about
something more fun I guess I saw this
article in world star fellas do do y'all
pay on the first date or is it 5050 you
know what I mean listen I haven't dated
in a
while but even when I first went out it
was like even when I go out my friends I
pay you know what I mean like I don't
know
like I don't like anybody that has like
set rules for this like if you're
looking for that you know like you go
out on a
date it's like if you ask somebody out
right you go hey do you want to go to
dinner with
me I should
pay right I asked you to
go and that's you I think it should be a
thing where you like but I don't know
I don't know what you modern kids are
doing right now y'all have these weird
ideas you know it's like and then you
got and then you might have even the you
know the the sort of feminist girl who's
like I could pay for myself I don't need
nobody pay for me you know do you like
that kind of person or is it just like
all right let's go out on a date and you
go if someone's like okay I'll pay you
might be like all right why don't why
don't I pay this time and then on the
second date you could pay maybe you have
a discussion like that
but I don't do this 50/50 thing you know
unless just
like what I'm saying is when I go if I'm
if I back in the day if I'm taking
somebody out I know I'm going to pay if
when the check comes and I put my credit
card down and that person goes you know
girl oh you know what put just split it
you might be like oh cool that's cool
but then at that point you could be like
no no it's so it's thank I got it don't
worry hey if I get a second date you can
pay then right right or whatever you
know or you might be somebody that's
like oh cool this chick's dope all right
yeah split that but
like going into
it I think you
should you should pay you know what I
mean if you a dude you should pay or
whoever's asking you I'm saying whoever
the person is asking out if a if if a
boss if a boss lady is like comes to you
and says you know what I like you and I
want to take you to dinner You' be like
oh okay take me to dinner then but like
for the most part you're asking the
person out so my thing is like whoever's
asking the person out and suggesting
where to go and setting it up they
should
pay right is that am I crazy am I crazy
so I don't know like we're and this
ain't to me we don't got to make this
about being a gentleman we don't got to
make it about like oh this is the man's
obligation I just think it's a matter of
like what do you do when you go with
your boys you call your you know you say
you might if you your friend you go yo
dude you want to go dinner let's go
dinner then you get there and then while
you're at dinner you like oh you want to
split it you know and then we just split
it I go out with my comic friends all
the time A lot of times sometimes I'm
like the bill and I go I got it guys you
can get the next one whatever it may be
it's just like who are you but like for
this this whole thing about dating and
the etiquette of dating and and and how
you know and then these women that are
coming with this stuff like oh the
places I don't want to go I'm not going
to Applebees I'm not going it's like
what what
what bye
like you don't want to be a person like
that I think if you want to find out
what a chick's really about all the L
things all the places they say don't
take them take them there first just to
see just to see oh you don't want coffee
on the first date okay oh we going to
get coffee I'll meet you for coffee
there's some good coffee place
go to one of these bougie coffee places
in and be like yeah you just wanted to
sit and talk hey how you doing just you
know some casual you don't you you need
to a dude got to drop $150 on you and
first of all that ain't even special
stop acting like being taken to dinner
is special
listen we got to
eat I like
steak we go into a steakhouse not for
you for
me if you think that
special if you think that because a dude
who's got the
money buy some fancy dinner well now I
feel raise your level of what you think
special is that's why people get taken
advantage of that's how stuff gets
misconstrued because it ain't special I
eat fancy all the time if I was single
and I'm like oh yeah yeah we yeah I want
to go to uh boa you know we going to we
not going to boa cuz you special we're
going to boa cuz Daddy likes boa and I
got the money to and if I have the money
to pay for B what does it really mean
you special is doing something for
someone that's special to them and it
don't even have to be fancy dinners or
what what if the person
likes you know a special kind of food
that they they they that they have a
connection like they just moved here and
they're like oh you know I have't had
this kind of food in a while it reminds
me of my family and then you take this
chick out on a date and you take it to a
restaurant like that that means more and
it don't even have to be expensive it's
like make it mean something what special
is and what it's like GH this generation
man you know what I
mean trash I don't know all y'all
trash all right guys we we going to
finish up with this article that I saw
that I was talking about this weeks ago
remember when I was talking about this
remember when I was like and I was
telling you how I was on Instagram and
and and these idiots were like all I
said was they they they they said they
were going to raise the minimum wage to
$20 an hour at fast food restaurants and
I said well get ready for no toy and a
$75 happy meal and everybody was getting
on my case oh what a you know I was I
was like this is about greed and sure
enough here we go guys in California
here we go McDonald's chipotle to raise
menu prices in California next year as
fast food rages rise to $220 an hour so
now check this out on those dates oh we
going to McDonald's now because
McDonald's got boa prices
now you know what I'm saying so now you
going to go to the fast food restaurant
being like yeah um hey babe yeah can we
get a table for two uh you want big ma
Big B meal cuz it's now $35 for a Big
Mac meal you know what I mean like since
you want men to spend a lot of money
well it's going to be at a fast food
restaurant but I knew this was going to
happen now it makes me feel like it
makes me feel like it's all a scam the
whole thing makes me feel like the
governor is like hey let's raise minimum
wage
and then so then the other people could
be like the fast food people who's who
he's in bed with is like how can we
raise prices how can we make more money
and he's like all right well we'll just
raise the minimum wage because and
ultimately that's not a lot of money if
you think about it like how much money
is that really they probably going to
hire less workers they're going to have
more this like a electronic AI stuff
anyway where you self-service stuff
anyway they'll have less workers make it
$20 an hour but now they're going to be
making way much way more profit because
they've raised their
prices I don't it's like the whole
thing's a scam man the whole thing the
the you know you know what I mean like
you can't trust nothing right that's
what I think about it because it's like
and it's not just going to be McDonald's
and Chipotle I've seen articles they're
all every fast food restaurant in
California is going to raise their
prices they're gonna raise their prices
you're gonna go to In-N-Out now it's
gonna be like wait what
like fast food is the first of
all the whole justification for raising
the minimum wage to fast food workers
for $20 an hour is that the fast food
worker
sometimes is the only bread winner in
lowincome families right so they said
well we gotta we got to raise the
minimum wage for those
people but guess where lowincome
families
eat fast food
restaurants so now they can't afford
it it's the circle of
life anyways
whatever you know what I mean like I
just I don't know this it it's a crazy
world man it's a hard knock life dude so
I
just I I it's it's it's a vicious circle
of of of
nonsense you know what I
mean it's just a vicious circle of
nonsense and who knows when it's going
to end but now we going and it's going
to be like
$75 for like you you gonna go to you
gonna go have a family of five gonna go
to McDonald's and they gonna be like we
can't even afford this so then what then
then what then what's gonna happen
because it's not like they raising the
quality of the stuff where every but
people that can afford people that can
afford it they're already going to
restaurants where they're already paying
people more those people those workers
are making more money off tips and stuff
like that than they would at this place
like they're not raising the quality of
the food you know what I mean so I don't
know we you know we we'll see I'll I'll
keep you posted as to like how this is
going man you know I will keep you
posted
anyways we having a short episode today
y'all so you know what time it
is on that rap
recap sometimes people in the chat need
to get
slapped the comments are
whack they need a k k
k that's a fact woo we got the SAG
strike it ain't
right we still in the
fight let's do it
[Music]
right prices going up we going to feel
it in our
gut and I
but
yeah riing with
Griffin H tune in every
[Music]
week all right y'all thanks for watching
riffing with Griffin I appreciate you
guys being here even some of you troll
ass [__] you know who you
are and so as a matter of fact you know
what before I leave let me get let me
let me give a timeout I haven't given a
timeout in chat in a while but anyways
thanks for being here and I will see you
next
week
yeah